So, da bin ich! Ich glaube die Musik ist zu relaxing gerade, da bett man ja ein bei.
Zu relaxing, jetzt zu laut ein bisschen. So viel wupp wupp wupp. Jaja, es war gut. Bisschen
laut ist es immer noch. Kann sich weder hier entscheiden. Ja ok. So Leute, erster Arbeitstag
rum und wie wars bei euch? Ich weiß das einige bei euch auch heute ersten Tag hatten. Also,
was ich bei mir sagen kann ist es ist, was ich sagen kann, wielys abgelenkt vom zweiten
Bildschirm. Es ist Abkürzungs ré staff leute.
Es
Die haben ja, okay, der alte Laden, wo ich gewesen bin, der hatte ja schon viele Abkürzungen, ja.
Und die übertreiben es richtig.
Die übertreiben es komplett.
Da ist jedes zweite Wort irgendeine Abkürzung.
Und dann auch noch irgendeine interne Abkürzung.
Ich gucke gerade in meine E-Mails.
Ich habe heute noch gar nicht in die E-Mails reingeguckt.
Und gerade eine Frage, wer da wieder rumspammt.
Wisst ihr, was ein Monatsticket mittlerweile kostet?
Die sind wirklich nicht mehr ganz dicht.
Ich habe geguckt, ein Monatsticket von mir zur Arbeit kostet 175 Euro.
Und es ist nicht weit.
175 Euro.
Und das ist nur eine kurze Strecke.
Mit 49-Euro-Ticket ist das halbwegs erschwinglich und irgendwie auch wieder lohnenswert.
Aber 175 Euro.
Ich meine, du kannst dafür theoretisch fast Auto fahren.
Wenn du wirklich nur diese Strecke fährst.
Ich meine, insgesamt kostet das Auto im Monat natürlich mehr.
Aber wenn du wirklich nur diese Strecke, also auch mit Tanken und sowas.
Ich meine, ich habe ja eh ein Elektroauto, da sieht es wieder anders aus.
Also wahrscheinlich ist es billiger, tatsächlich mit dem Auto zu fahren.
Gut, wenn du wahrscheinlich alles einrechnest, so von Abnutzung bis vielleicht...
Aber selbst dann, das ist schon ordentlich.
Ihr habt ein riesiges Confluence nur für die Abkürzung.
Ja gut, sowas nennt man ja auch Glossar.
Das ist ja schon ganz sinnvoll.
Ob man jetzt nur ein eigenes Confluence dafür braucht?
Ja, also ich bin aufgestanden heute so kurz nach sieben.
Und ich war um...
Ich würde sagen so um...
Um 17 Uhr ungefähr war ich wieder daheim.
Also zehn Stunden von aufstehen bis heimkommen.
Das geht eigentlich durchaus, ja.
Aber...
Das sieht man halt wieder, wie nice Homeoffice ist.
Und...
Ich musste halt heute auch erstmal gucken, dass alles funktioniert, ja.
Von Notebook bis Teams-Zugang und Remote-Möglichkeiten und sowas.
Im Detail kann ich es euch natürlich nicht erzählen.
Aber es ist halt immer ein größerer Akt.
Ich war begeistert.
Ohne Scheiß, ohne Scheiß.
Also bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber wäre es ein Ding der Unmöglichkeit gewesen,
dass ich dort anfange und am gleichen Tag noch einen funktionierenden Account,
Notebook, Handy und Login und alles habe.
Ich meine, okay, alles wird beim neuen auch noch nicht gehen.
Aber...
Also muss ich sagen, es ist Hut ab.
Das ist nicht verkehrt, ja.
Schon nicht schlecht.
Schon nicht schlecht, dass sie das alles so hingekriegt haben.
Kann man, denke ich, nichts sagen.
Also das habe ich schon deutlich schlimmer gesehen.
Erstmal Twitch, ja.
Erstmal die Leuten Kackel beibringen.
MonkaS.
Kack Wade.
Wirst du Homeoffice machen können?
Ja.
Das ist ja...
Übrigens, mein Chef heißt auch Daniel mit Vorname.
Ganz lustig, gerade, dass du im Chat bist.
Wirst du Homeoffice machen können?
Ja.
Aktuell ist es einmal...
Die Woche, wo ich nach Frankfurt muss.
Aber so perspektivisch ist es wahrscheinlich einmal alle 14 Tage.
Ist das dein Chef?
Glaube ich nicht, wäre ein ganz schön großer Zufall.
Wie agil seid ihr?
Also was ich bis jetzt mitbekommen habe, ist,
dass der gesamte Laden...
Ich meine, das ist ein riesen Finanzdienstleister
mit tausenden Mitarbeitern oder so.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viele die insgesamt haben.
Die sind nicht sonderlich agil.
Es gibt so ein paar Projekte,
was ich heute am ersten Tag so mitbekommen habe.
Es gibt natürlich mal Projekte, wo sie sagen,
sie sind super agil.
Aber wenn ich dann schon mitbekomme,
dass es statische Kubernetes-Environments gibt,
die von Hand gepflegt werden teilweise.
Was heißt von Hand?
So händisch immer angepasst werden.
Also es ist schon ein bisschen...
Oldschool.
Aber das finde ich gar nicht schlecht.
Ich meine, gerade Finanzdienstleister haben ja auch gewisse Auflagen.
Das macht, denke ich, schon Sinn.
Und der große Vorteil bei denen versus meinem alten Arbeitgeber,
was ich bis jetzt sehe, ist,
die sind nicht einfach nur, sagen wir mal so,
so elefantenmäßig unterwegs,
sondern wenigstens auch gründlich.
Also da weiß dann auch wirklich jeder an jeder...
Naja, jeder an jeder Stelle ist immer ein bisschen übertrieben.
Aber an den meisten Stellen, wie jetzt der Ablauf sein muss,
das ist eigentlich ganz nice.
Nicht so dieses theoretisch, die wissen was,
aber wir halten uns nicht dran.
Sondern ich glaube, die nehmen das schon wirklich...
Ernst, ja.
Hast du nicht mehr montags frei?
Doch, habe ich.
Ich bin heute hingegangen.
Und wisst ihr, was ich auch sehr nett fand?
Oder sehr mitgedacht?
Ich habe heute meinen Chef gefragt,
so ja, wie ist denn das?
Also ich bin jetzt ja montags da.
Normalerweise bin ich...
Bin ich ja montags nicht da.
Ausnahmsweise.
Dann bleibe ich einfach Freitag daheim.
Dann meinte er, nee, nee, bleib mal Donnerstag daheim.
Freitag ist doch Feiertag.
Das war doch okay.
Habe ich gar nicht dran gedacht.
Der alte Laden hätte das bestimmt...
Hätte bestimmt nichts gesagt,
in der Hoffnung, ich kriege es nicht mit.
Also, insofern, bis jetzt...
Also die haben wirklich einen guten Eindruck gemacht.
Auch der eine, der da war,
der mir ein bisschen die Sachen gezeigt hat,
der hat sich auch Mühe gegeben.
Die haben im Vorfeld extra so eine Mindmap erstellt mit Dingern.
Aber ich meine, ich habe am ersten Tag null durchgeblickt.
So 30 Milliarden Abkürzungen.
Das Einzige, was ich teilweise verstanden habe,
ist, wenn sie was von Google Cloud und Terraform und sowas erzählt haben.
Ansonsten habe ich nicht wirklich viel verstanden.
Wir haben zweimal Max im Team.
Mich und noch einen anderen.
Müssen wir uns mal gucken, wie wir uns jetzt verständigen,
wer wann wie wo gemeint ist.
Ist das wieder eine Bank?
Ja, nicht direkt.
Aber geht in die Richtung.
Ja, so hundertprozentig.
Weil ansonsten kann man sich so sehr...
Kann man sich relativ...
zu sehr einschränken.
Wobblos auf der Nahe.
Wobblos.
Da würde ich mal gucken, Alter.
Wenn die Leute im Meeting sagen,
Wobblos, was sagst du so?
Was sagst du hier dazu?
Kann man den Link aufmachen, ohne dass man sich irgendwas einfällt?
Dass man sich irgendwas einfängt?
Was sagst du hierzu?
Äh, den Screenshot verstehe ich nicht.
Nein, es wurde nur alles an Zugängen haben wir ausprobiert.
Ich habe, ich habe mich angemeldet überall und so.
Nee.
Und ich glaube auch, bis ich richtig an irgendwelchen Live-Systemen was sinnvoll machen kann,
wird wahrscheinlich auch noch der ein oder andere Tag vergehen.
Für mich heißen die Systeme einfach nur alle furchtbar kryptisch zur Zeit.
Hast du mal Zeit darauf...
Was hast du mal darauf reagiert?
Was kann...
Ich kann nicht mehr lesen, Leute.
Kannst du mal darauf reagieren?
Er redet darüber, dass die Arbeit bei der...
Was, dass die Arbeit bei der Arbeit besser ist als Homeoffice.
Ach, er schon wieder.
Redet er darüber oder redet der Blogartikel darüber?
Ich meine, wir können jetzt ja schlecht...
Reacten.
Auf die Blog-Reacting-Reaction.
Wobei, warum eigentlich nicht?
Das ist das, wie die ganzen großen Reaction-Channels auch ihren Content produzieren die ganze Zeit.
Leko, danke schön für den Sub.
Ach ja, die Frage kam doch eben irgendwo, ob ich schon Arched auf dem Notebook installiert hätte, gell?
Irgendwo.
Wo war das denn?
Arched.
Hier, und schon Arched auf dem Notebook installiert.
Nee.
Und jetzt, jetzt kommt, jetzt, jetzt kommt der Hammer.
Da will ich ja mal gespannt...
Wie sie das machen wollen, auf Dauer.
Also, beziehungsweise, sie machen das ja schon auf Dauer.
Aber...
Wie lange ich das aushalte, ohne zu meckern.
Und zwar, ich hab natürlich erstmal nen Windows-Notebook in die Hand gedrückt bekommen.
Was auch sonst, ja.
Das alleine wär ja noch nicht so schlimm gewesen.
Aber, jetzt haltet euch mal fest.
Es gibt doch diesen Windows-Notebook.
Nicht mal WSL.
Und auch kein neues Terminal.
Nicht von Visual Studio Code.
Okay, das kann man sich nachinstallieren lassen.
Das kann man sich nachinstallieren lassen.
Nee, nee, es ist, es ist, es ist...
Ich glaub, ich glaub, es ist Windows 10.
Ist es noch.
Nicht mal WSL, ja.
Dafür gibt es wohl...
Irgendwo Putty.
Putty, Alter.
Putty. Und...
Man kann...
Man kann, ähm...
Sich irgendwo in, in Azure ne Linux-VM aufsetzen lassen.
Wo man sich dann per Putty drauf connecten oder per MOBA Xterm drauf connecten kann.
Und von, die kann man sich dann einrichten, wie man will.
Vor allem, es ist ne Red Hat-VM.
Weil Red Hat auch so ne geile, geiles Arbeitsbetriebssystem ist.
Red Hat.
Ich hab jetzt ne VM angelegt mit Red Hat 9 drauf.
Also...
Ich glaube...
Ich glaube, da werde ich in Zukunft ein bisschen meckern müssen.
Wenn man eine gescheite Arbeitsumgebung hat.
Also, ich werde erstmal Westterm auf das Notebook drauf machen.
Das braucht, glaube ich, keine...
Braucht, glaube ich, keine Installation.
Warte mal, für Windows?
Äh, wo...
Ist das das?
Ja, das ist ein Zip.
Ich, ich, ich meine, ich habe es noch nie unter...
Noch nie unter Windows benutzt.
Aber das kann man, das kann man anscheinend auch ohne Installation benutzen.
So, das ist das, das ist das...
Das ist das erste, was ich mir auf jeden Fall schon mal draufhauen werde.
Wo ist es denn?
Eine Runde Westterm.
Habe ich übrigens noch nie unter Windows gestartet.
Wie sieht das denn jetzt aus?
Westterm GUI.
Ja, ist ja gut, ey.
Da ist es.
Ja, das kann man wenigstens halbwegs gescheit verwenden.
Okay, standardmäßig sieht das äußerst cringe aus.
Aber immerhin.
Immerhin ein halbwegs...
Halbwegs gescheites Terminal.
Da muss man jetzt halt die Fallshell und alles noch anpassen.
Aber es passt schon.
Schau mal, deine Config importieren kannst.
Ne, da fehlt mir allein schon die Schriftart und sowas.
Werde ich dann, werde ich, werde ich machen.
Gucken, wo das, mal gucken, wo das die Config...
Das werde ich morgen ausprobieren.
Auf dem, auf dem Arbeitsnotebook.
Tja, weil die erst, weil, weil die keinen Linux Notebook haben.
Ich werde, ich werde den schon in nächster Zeit auf den Keks gehen.
Weil das ist unglaublich nervig.
Ohne gescheites Terminal.
Äh, mit W...
Selbst mit WSL konnte man nicht alles gescheit machen.
Man braucht ja vielleicht auch mal irgendein UI-Programm.
Und sei es nur ein Wireshark, um irgendwas zu dumpen oder so.
Oder sei es, dass ich Kubernetes-mäßig mal was ausprobieren will.
Und Minikube starten mit Docker.
Mach das mal unter Windows.
Das geht ja überhaupt nicht.
Ähm, pff, ey, nee.
Mal gucken, ob ich mich irgendwie über das Arbeitsnotebook tunneln kann dann.
Von der Linux-VM daheim.
Und mal gucken, ob das erlaubt ist.
Nee.
Das geht nicht.
Weil ich keine Admin-Rechte hab, was zu installieren.
Nur weil was theoretisch lauffähig wäre unter Windows.
Heißt ja nicht, dass es auch lauft, äh, dass es auch lauffähig ist unter den aktuellen Gegebenheiten.
Senior Linux.
Senior Linux-Engineer unter Linux.
Äh, ich hab schon gesehen.
Es gibt dort auch Tage, die einfach von 9 bis 16 Uhr 30 Meeting dauerhaft sind.
Ja.
Senior Meeting-Engineer, ja.
Pogger-Subscription.
Der Firmen-Laptop, Leute, das hab ich noch nie gesehen.
Das Ding wurde installiert und ungelogen.
Wusstet ihr, dass man das hier ausblenden kann?
Wusstet ihr, dass es ein Setting gibt?
Wusstet ihr, dass das hier unendlich lang sein kann?
Die gesamte, ohne Scheiß.
Das hab ich noch nie gesehen.
Die gesamte, aber ohne Mist, Leute.
Die gesamte Taskleiste ist voll mit Icons.
Die haben da 18 verschiedene Security-Tools drauf installiert.
Aber gut, das muss alles highly secure sein.
Ja, wenn man Linux verwenden würde, bräuchte man's wahrscheinlich nicht, ja.
Und das ist lahm teilweise.
Oh, Mann.
Nee, das Microsoft-Video hab ich nicht gesehen.
Ja, geht mir im Prinzip auch so.
Nee, CPU-Auslastung ist gar nicht so hoch.
Aber sobald du was Neues aufmachst, leckt's erst mal rum,
weil 30.000 Viren-Scanner was scannen müssen.
Ich hab eigentlich jetzt schon mehr oder weniger alles gesagt.
Es war ein Riesen-Aus-, nicht auswendig, ein Riesen-Anzahl an Abkürzungen am ersten Tag.
Es bestand alles nur aus Abkürzungen.
Alles hatte Abkürzungen.
Und nachdem das auch oftmals sehr kurze Abkürzungen sind,
würd mich nicht wundern, wenn die Abkürzungen auch doppelt belegt wären.
Waren sie zufrieden? Das weiß ich nicht.
Ich hab ja noch nix gemacht.
Die absurdeste Abkürzung weiß ich nicht.
Nee, absurd waren die eigentlich nicht.
Die haben schon Sinn gemacht.
Aber es waren halt viele.
So, und im Detail kann ich euch ja nicht die Abkürzungen erzählen,
beziehungsweise was dahinter steckt.
Vielleicht liegt das irgendwas.
Gab's Keck W als Abkürzung?
Nee, das hab ich noch nicht gesehen.
Aber da bin ich dafür, das als ersten Service einzuführen.
Keck W, der Keck W-Service.
Also nein, das hab ich noch nicht gemacht.
Ich kann ja auch kein Arch benutzen zurzeit, weil ich nen Windows-Notebook hab.
So, morgen Homeoffice, dann richte ich das mal alles ein bisschen schöner ein.
Und so, dass man irgendwie halbwegs alles verwenden kann.
Ja, das ist...
Ich glaube, das ist noch Windows 10 gewesen.
Ja, wenn ich das richtig, richtig im Blick hab.
Nee, da kannst du nix selbst drauf installieren.
Admin-Rechte geben, ja, ist klar.
Das frag ich mich auch, ehrlich gesagt.
Also ich hab heut bei nem Kollege gesehen, dass der irgendwie Mobile Xterm offen hatte mit 100 Tabs.
Wobei ich Anfälle bekomme, wenn ich produktiv mit Mobile Xterm arbeiten muss.
Wenn man ein gescheites Homeoffice hat.
Wenn man ein gescheites, lagfreies Terminal gewöhnt ist.
Nee, nee, ich kann da nicht einfach...
Leute, ich kann nicht einfach über USB was nachinstallieren.
Ich brauch ja die Windows-Sachen, ja.
Zum Einloggen, zum Anmelden, zum dran teilnehmen, zum reingucken.
Es ist nicht so, dass es unsinnig ist, dass da Windows drauf ist.
Ich persönlich fänd das sehr nice, wenn man vielleicht noch ein zweites Notebook bekommen würde, zum Linux drauf machen.
Ich werde das vielleicht mal anregen in Zukunft.
Ich könnte mir halt vorstellen...
...dass sie da sehr pingelig sind.
Red Hat mag auf dem Server gut sein, als Arbeitssystem ist es nix.
Sollte ich vielleicht machen.
Ich kann aus religiösen Gründen nicht mit Windows arbeiten.
Warum nicht?
Also Windows kann ich ja verstehen.
Aber Azure und Google Cloud sind doch vollkommen in Ordnung.
Was war das für ein ZIP-Programm?
Das war pzip.
Tabi.sh
Das ist nur Windows, oder wie?
44,5, Alter, was ist denn da los?
Ist das Windows-only?
Ah, hier.
SSH und Serial-Client for Windows.
Das sieht gar nicht, das klingt gar nicht so übel.
Braucht das Admin-Rechte?
Javascript, ja, das ist mir egal.
Der Rechner ist gut.
Das Notebook ist gut, was ich bekommen hab.
32G RAM und ein i7 13000 irgendeine App ist da.
13000 irgendeine App ist da.
Also, Mobile, i7 oder i5, ne ich glaub i7.
Das Notebook ist wirklich, ist wirklich sehr potent.
Gibt's hier auch nicht Pre-Releases, Leute?
Was normales vielleicht?
Ne, irgendein, ich glaub irgendein HP-Notebook?
Gibt nur Alpha-Software hier.
Portable, das brauch ich.
Portable x64.
Ok, das, das hört sich auch nicht so schlecht an.
Oh ne, das ist das falsche.
Wo war ich jetzt?
Leute, ich blick da mal durch.
Downloads?
Hier.
Ne, leider kein, leider kein Thinkpad.
Aber, ohne Mist, unter Windows laufen die eigentlich alle ganz gut.
Moment, ist das, ist das ein Elektron?
Ist das, ist das browserbasiertes Terminal?
Seh ich das hier richtig?
Ok, erstmal 800 MB RAM weg.
Beim Start.
Machen wir das doch mal.
Warte mal, ich mach das mal kurz auf.
Mal gucken, ob das was taugt.
Leute, ich hab ne PCI Express SSD mit 5000 MB die Sekunde, sequenziell und, ja ok, jetzt ist es fertig.
Rename, das hier ist doch, ja.
Tabi.
Boah, da krieg ich ja, ich dreh ja schon am Rad, wenn ich das sehe.
Enable Analytics, nein.
Enable Global Hotkey, nein.
Naja, vielleicht.
Jetzt hier erstmal nicht.
Language, Englisch, UK.
Hey, US, Kokona.
Ja, ok.
Jetzt bräuchte ich nur noch irgendeine ZSH oder so.
Aber von da, von da kann man sich ja dann wenigstens auf irgendeine, irgendeine andere VM verbinden, um gut ist.
Ja, wird schon passen.
Ich denk das geht schon.
Senior Meeting Champ, ja.
Ja, ich stream schon ne ganze Weile.
Halt, meistens keinerlei Gaming-Geschichten, ja.
Wenn du bei mir mal guckst in der, in der Streaming-History, da wirst du feststellen.
Mensch, Twitch, kriegt mal eure Domains auf die Reihe.
Max, Klappe.
Ja, wenn du dir die History anguckst, was wir so gemacht haben.
Arch, Arch Linux Packages gebaut.
GitHub Actions uns angeguckt.
TrueNAS Gale.
C Sharp programmiert.
Das hat ja nichts mit YouTube Content zu tun.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ach, ich werd das schon irgendwie auf die Reihe kriegen.
Jasper, danke für den Sub.
Wie gesagt, das hab ich nicht gesehen.
Bist du als Streamer erkannt?
Nein.
Nein, nein.
Quatsch.
Ich mein, so bekannt ist mein Twitch-Stream jetzt auch nicht.
YouTube kennen vielleicht die einen oder anderen.
Aber Twitch guckt doch im Vergleich zu vielen anderen.
Auf Twitch sind ja hier nicht viele Leute.
Ich hab im Durchschnitt sowas zwischen 230 oder so Zuschauer.
Im Schnitt 220, 230 oder so.
Ey, aber man muss sagen, ich finde für Technik-Streams und das, was wir machen,
ist das gar nicht schlecht.
Ist schon, ist eigentlich wirklich okay.
Aber im Vergleich zu großen Gaming-Streams auf Twitch ist das natürlich gar nichts.
Ja.
Wie viele, weiß das jemand von euch?
Wie viele Zuschauer hat Ninja eigentlich aktuell noch?
Das war ja mal vor, ja so drei, vier Jahren.
Ist ja schon eine ganze Weile her.
Das war ja noch vor Corona.
Der größte Streamer ever.
Ich mein, der wird mehr als drei Zuschauer haben aktuell.
Aber wahrscheinlich immer noch ziemlich viele.
Aber wahrscheinlich nicht mehr in den Sphären, wie als der Fortnite-Hype so mega groß war.
Gibt es kostenloses Wasser und Obst?
Nee, weder das eine noch das andere.
Bei uns gibt es keck.
Kundeneinwilligungserklärung.
Ah, das finde ich cool.
Das finde ich cool.
Könnte man da nicht noch irgendwie, irgendwie Kundenerklärung, Einwilligung oder so rausmachen?
Weil da könnte man das wirklich wegen dem W keck W nennen.
Spieler zahlen bei Battlefield.
Okay, Moment.
Hey, die sind, die sind, glaube ich, gase für Battlefield 2042-Verhältnisse.
Die sind, glaube ich, gar nicht so mies.
Ja.
Also für Battlefield-Verhältnisse sind die gar nicht so mies.
Die waren schon, die waren schon schlechter.
Ich verstehe zwar nicht, wie das einer wirklich am Stück spielen kann.
Aber okay.
Und jetzt muss ich mal gucken.
New World, Steam Stats.
Oh, das ist wirklich schlecht, Alter.
Wendet ihr fort.
Also ich glaube, das habe ich auch bei einem MMO noch nicht gesehen.
Ey.
Ich glaube, dass die angefangen haben mit einer Million und innerhalb quasi von einem Jahr.
Hier haben sie ja die neuen Server gestartet.
Neue Server ziehen immer neue Leute an.
Deswegen klappen die Seasons auch so gut.
Gerade bei Games wie Path of Exile und sowas.
Ah, das ist krass.
Guck mal, die haben es geschafft innerhalb von einem halben Jahr.
In einem halben Jahr, Mann.
Runter.
Von einer Million auf 22.000.
Das ist.
Ne.
Boah, das ist, das ist echt.
Das habe ich, also diesen krassen Abrutsch, Abfall habe ich ja noch nirgendwo gesehen.
Wurdest du auf der Arbeit schon gefragt, wie du C++ findest?
Ne.
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass ich in nächster Zeit gefragt werde.
Du Max, was sagst du zu C++?
Nö.
Die haben alle ein Video aus Lootbook.
Alle.
Also Linux Admins.
Ja, aber die haben alle ein Windows Notebook.
Das widerspricht sich vielleicht ein bisschen, aber ja.
Ist halt so.
Ja, bestimmt.
Ist, ist schon, ist immer irgendwie so.
Gerade wenn du bei dem neuen Zeug noch nicht so richtig drinnen bist.
Aber, ne, wirklich, wirklich.
Also das einzige, was man ja da vermisst, ist nicht die alte Firma.
Sondern, dass man sich dort an alles gewöhnt hatte.
Das ist ja wahrscheinlich das, was man vermisst.
Die alte Firma wird man nicht wirklich vermissen.
Weil die ist ja auch der Grund, warum man überhaupt abgehauen ist.
Gibt's Virtualbox Portable?
Ich glaube nicht, dass du irgendeine Virtualisierungslösung installieren kannst unter Windows, die nicht Adminrechte braucht.
Allein schon fürs Installieren von irgendwelchen Netzwerktreibern und sowas.
Doch, das neue Windows Terminal ist ganz okay.
Aber das ist ja natürlich da nicht drauf.
Oh, Cycwin hör mal auf.
Das werde ich nie wieder benutzen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Das wirkt alles sehr oldschool, was sie da vorinstalliert haben.
Portable Virtualbox Instructions.
Ernsthaft?
Das gibt's wirklich?
Ja, aber allein schon durch die Netzwerktreiber wird das doch nicht funktionieren.
Das ist auch wahrscheinlich nicht erlaubt, denke ich mal.
Ne, es gibt so ein Portal, worüber man was installieren kann.
Aber da ist nichts dabei, was jetzt mein Arbeiten unter Windows viel angenehmer macht.
Vielleicht Visual Studio Code, aber das war's.
Hast du eigentlich dieses Jahr wieder den ganzen Dezember frei?
Boah, das weiß ich noch nicht, wie ich das mache.
Hängt wahrscheinlich ein bisschen davon ab, wie die anderen da Bock haben.
Also bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber fanden es die Leute eigentlich recht nice.
Weil es war immer das ganze Jahr über garantiert jemand am Start.
Die konnten im Sommer und sonst wie immer Urlaub machen, wie sie wollten.
Dezember ist aber halt normalerweise recht beliebt.
Ja, mal gucken.
Das stellt sich dann schon auch raus.
Wie das ist.
Mit HotTube-Streams wären es mehr Zuschauer.
Das ist bezweifelich, dass die Leute mich sehen wollen in der Badewanne.
Das geht auch mit dem offiziellen Image.
Echt?
Tatsächlich.
Das kann aber doch gar nicht funktionieren.
Weil du brauchst doch einen Netzwerktreiber, dass das klappt.
Und den kannst du nur installieren, wenn du Adminrechte hast.
Dachte ich jetzt eigentlich.
Hattest du schon HR-Onboarding-Stuff?
Das hatte ich im Vorfeld schon alles.
Ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung.
Aber ich bin ja eh nicht der große Überstunden-Macher.
Ich guck immer, dass ich plus minus null bin.
Und passt.
Hey Max, ist das, was du auf der Arbeit machst, noch klassische FISI-Arbeit?
Boah, das ist schwer zu sagen.
Gibt es klassische FISI-Arbeit mittlerweile?
Ich meine, das ist so breit gefächert.
Gerade was du als FISI später machst.
Ich kenne sogar Leute, die haben eine FISI-Ausbildung gemacht und programmieren jetzt.
Hauptberuflich.
Ich würde sagen, es ist schon ein bisschen weg von dieser Standard-Geschichte, wie man es beim FISI sich denkt.
Netzwerk, Config und ein bisschen Betriebssystem-Geklicke.
Client Support mache ich selbstverständlich auch keinen.
Würde ich im Leben irgendwann haben.
Client Support ist wirklich das allerletzte, was ich machen würde.
Ja, es ist schon nicht so das klassische FISI-Zeug, wie es sich die IHK denkt.
Aber viele FISIs machen in ihrer Ausbildung auch nicht das klassische Zeug, wie sich das die IHK denkt.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Nee, nee, nee.
Du brauchst...
Ach so.
Ja.
Okay.
Das würde gehen.
Eine USB-Netzwerkkarte anschließen und die durchreichen in die VM.
Ja, das würde...
Das würde wahrscheinlich...
Das würde wahrscheinlich gehen.
Interessiert dich Entwicklung auch wie Systemadministration?
Ich würde nicht sagen, dass mich klassische Systemadministration was ist, was mich groß interessiert.
Ich meine, ich bin zwar Server-Admin in dem Sinn.
Ja, das ist auch das, was ich quasi gelernt habe beim Provider.
Aber es ist jetzt...
Ich kenne keinen, der sagt, oh ja, Systemadministration ist das, was mir super viel Spaß macht.
Systemadministration ist meistens relativ langweilig.
Systemadministration ist meistens relativ langweiliges Zeug.
Da legst irgendwie einen User an, checkst irgendwelche Rechte auf irgendeinen Share und so was.
Das Drumherum ist deutlich interessanter als Systemadministration an sich.
Aber du bist doch öfters im Stream.
Du hast doch auch schon gesehen, dass wir viele Programmier-Streams gemacht haben.
Ich meine, würde ich Programmier-Streams machen, wenn mich Software-Entwicklung nicht
interessieren würde?
Oder Chat, was meinst du?
Das ist illegaler als Physi zu programmieren.
Ja, kriegst dann...
Instant ist die Abmahnung in der Post.
Hast du einen Tipp?
End-User-Support oder was?
Naja, dich woanders bewerben.
Weil wenn du quasi im Support bist, dann wirst du ja logischerweise auch Support machen müssen.
Du kannst intern gucken.
Die meisten Arbeitgeber haben ja intern auch so ein Job-Portal.
Also die gucken ja intern erstmal, ob Leute Bock haben, bevor sie sich da extern umgucken
und Bewerber suchen.
Da kannst du gucken.
Ansonsten musst du dich irgendwo anders bewerben.
Weil wenn du jetzt in irgendeinem Support-Team bist, ist es ja so illusorisch anzunehmen,
man würde keinen Support machen.
Dann Turnschuh-Administrator.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich ja noch halbwegs interessant.
Wenn man ins Rechenzentrum geht und im Rechenzentrum was einbaut und so.
Das ist aber nicht das, was ich unter Server-Administration vielleicht auch...
Aber für mich ist Server-Administration halt so super langweiliges Zeug.
Rechte von einem Ordner kontrollieren und sowas.
So das Einbauen...
Ich weiß nicht, in welche Kategorie das fällt.
Aber das Einbauen von einem Server oder das Wechseln von einem Lüfter und sowas.
Das würde ich schon...
Das ist eher Infrastruktur.
Das würde ich jetzt gar nicht so...
Auch wenn ich das früher beim Provider den ganzen Tag gemacht habe, so Dinger.
Da war ich ja mehrfach täglich im Rechenzentrum.
Das ist wirklich eine Sache...
Die finde ich ein bisschen blöd.
Dass ich so gar nicht mehr ins Rechenzentrum muss.
Die letzten Male war ich einfach nur just for fun, weil ich mal wieder Bock hatte ins Rechenzentrum zu gehen drinnen.
Nicht, weil ich musste.
Ich war ewig nicht mehr im Rechenzentrum bei uns.
Beim alten Arbeitgeber und beim neuen war ich noch gar nicht im Rechenzentrum.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo das ist.
Aber ich glaube, dass mein alter ein größeres eigenes Rechenzentrum hat als der neue.
Bin mir nicht sicher.
Keine Ahnung.
War ja noch nicht drin.
Null.
Ja, so ab und zu mal wieder ins Rechenzentrum.
Da hätte ich schon Bock drauf.
Nicht wirklich jetzt als hauptberuflicher Server auf Wagen rumfahrer oder so.
Oder auch nicht als Lüfter-Einbauer.
Aber ab und zu mal im Rechenzentrum mal wieder so ein Glasfaserkabel irgendwie bringen.
Ein Patchpanel.
Und vielleicht mal wieder mit 1-2 Leuten ein Playcenter einbauen oder sowas.
Wobei ich glaube kaum jemand benutzt heute noch Playcenter.
Habt ihr noch Playcenter auf der Arbeit Chat?
Wenn ich weiß was das ist.
Ich meine sowas hier.
Sowas hier meine ich.
Ja, mein alter Arbeitgeber hat die auch alle rausgeschmissen.
Ob der neue welche hat, weiß ich nicht.
Die waren cool die Dinger.
Die musste man aber mit mehreren Leuten einbauen.
Die Dinger sind glaube ich 8 HE hoch.
Oder ich glaube 8 HE.
Und extrem schwer.
Ich habe ja immer noch so einen Traum, was ich glaube.
Ich habe ja immer noch so einen Traum, was ich gerne mal im Rechenzentrum machen würde.
Das werde ich wahrscheinlich nie machen können.
Aber ich wollte schon immer mal gucken, wenn man so einen Playcenter auf leichtgängige Rollen schnallt.
So beispielsweise so ein Playcenter auf Inline Skates oder so schnallen.
Und dann ein Netzteil zieht, sodass die Lüfter volle Pulle gehen.
Oder irgendwas reinsteckt vorne, sodass die Lüfter volle Pulle gehen.
Ich wollte schon immer mal wissen, wie schnell so ein Playcenter werden kann.
Bei Lüfter volle Pulle.
Also auf leichtgängigen Rollen.
Weil...
Ich weiß nicht, ob es da Videos zu gibt, aber...
Die Dinger pusten dich...
Also die pusten dich nicht um.
Das ist jetzt übertrieben, wenn ich sage, die pusten dich um.
Aber die...
Wenn du dich hinter so einen Playcenter...
Ja.
Freunde, das ist aber falsch rum.
Der muss dahinter.
Ja.
Ne.
Ist das falsch rum?
Sind die andersrum jetzt?
Also ich habe die Plates immer vorne rein und raus gemacht.
Ja, anscheinend gibt es...
Playcenter Booting.
Sehr gutes Video.
Flugzeug startet, Leute.
Formel 1 Auto.
Da brauchst du einen Hörschutz.
Naja, ich hatte...
Wir hatten im Rechenzentrum früher immer Hörschutz...
Hängen.
Also so Hörer.
So Hörer am Eingang.
So ein Gehörschutz.
Aber ich habe die Dinger nie aufgezogen.
Ja, das würde ich ausprobieren.
Also es war so...
Wenn du hinter so einem Playcenter standest...
Wenn das volle Pulle geblasen hat.
Und wenn...
Wenn das Ding der Meinung war, dass ein Netzteil kaputt war...
Dann hat es...
Volle Pulle geblasen.
Und...
Playcenter wurden gerne unten in Racks eingebaut, weil die so groß und schwer sind.
Und wenn man dann an das Playcenter musste von hinten...
Dann hat man sich hinter das Playcenter gekniet.
Oder nicht so gekniet.
So in die Hocke ist man hinter das Playcenter gegangen.
Und hat dann dran rum...
Und wenn das angegangen ist und volle Pulle geblasen hat...
Dann konntest du wirklich nur schwierig in der Hocke hinter dem Playcenter sitzen.
So sehr hat es geblasen.
Also es hatte schon ordentlich Luftstrom, was da rausgekommen ist.
Ist jetzt keine...
Ist jetzt keine Flugzeugturbine.
Aber ist schon ordentlich.
Aha.
Auf studieren hätte ich gar keinen Bock mehr.
Wobei jetzt...
Durch den Chat habe ich wenigstens den IQ dafür.
Easy.
Ich würde sagen, wir gehen einfach kollektiv studieren.
Twitch Chat goes...
Twitch Chat plays...
Ähm...
Informatik studieren.
Backseating.
Mädchen-2-Server im Ads...
Moment.
Im Mädchen-2-Server kannst du doch auf jede...
Auf jedem...
Auf jeder Smartwatch heutzutage hosten.
Brauchst du doch nichts für...
Die kenne ich nicht.
Ja.
Ah, die Bahn hat heute Verspätung, Leute.
20 Minuten zu spät heimgekommen wegen dem Kackladen.
Ja.
Wenn du Lüfter rausgezogen hast oder Netzteil rausgezogen hast...
Oder das Ding der Meinung war...
Das Netzteil ist kaputt...
Dann ging es...
Es ist richtig los...
Es ist richtig hochgedreht alles.
So sieht es aus.
Deswegen...
Wir müssen mittlerweile richtig...
Massive High IQ haben.
Soll ich mal kurz gucken wie viel Subs...
Subscriber ich gerade habe.
Boah, wenn es danach geht...
Müsste ich glaube ich der...
Der High IQigste...
Mensch der Welt sein.
Wisst ihr was ich gemerkt habe?
Nick, danke schon für den Sub.
Das bringt unglaublich viel...
Wenn man...
Ich meine...
Okay.
Ihr werdet jetzt sagen, Max ist doch logisch.
Ja.
Hätte man auch selbst drauf kommen können.
Und ja.
Ich habe jetzt ja die letzten Tage...
Über relativ regelmäßig gestreamt.
Nicht...
Nicht jetzt irgendwie teilweise 7, 8 Stunden...
Wie das andere am Tag machen.
Aber relativ regelmäßig.
Sogar...
Sogar manchmal so an die 4 Stunden.
Das...
Das bringt...
Das bringt schon was...
Was...
Subscriptions und solche...
So...
So Dinge anbelangt.
Ja.
Ein Ja war klar.
Aber es macht schon einen Unterschied...
Ob man...
Zweimal die Woche...
Für 2 bis 3 Stunden streamt...
Oder ob man quasi...
3 bis 4 Stunden fast jeden Tag streamt.
Am besten wäre natürlich...
Wenn man das wirklich auch zu...
Geregelten Zeiten macht.
Also dass die Leute wissen...
Das Stream ist um so und so viel Uhr.
Und sowas.
Oder ungefähr immer dann und dann.
Aber das kriege ich nicht auf die Reihe.
Es gibt auch...
Es gibt auch Tage, da habe ich überhaupt keinen Bock.
Hättet ihr Studieren was gebracht?
Im Nachhinein betrachtet...
Das kann ich nicht sagen.
Weil ich ja nicht weiß...
Ob man...
Was ich dann gemacht hätte...
Es hätte ja durchaus meine...
Mein gesamter Werdegang potenziell anders verlaufen können.
Also wenn man jetzt davon ausgeht, ich hätte den absolut gleichen Weg...
...gemacht, wie jetzt.
Dann würde ich sagen hätten wir studieren...
Na ja...
Was heißt nichts gebracht, das kann man nicht sagen.
Ja, ein bisschen theoretisch, ein Background bei manchen Sachen...
Bei manchen...
Diggas...
Ist sicherlich...
Nie verkehrt...
aber im großen und ganzen würde ich sagen eher nicht ich habe fachinformatiker systemintegration
gelernt vor 15 jahren schon ein bisserl her bei einem internet provider aber keiner von
den großen also jetzt wenn du wenn jetzt eine ankommt naja null telekom den es war nicht die
telekom studieren in deutschland bringt immer was die aussage stimmt aber nur wenn du dir den
durchschnitt anguckt also wenn du quasi vom durchschnitt darauf schlussfolge ist dass es
immer was bringt weil die am durchschnitt theoretisch mehr verdient im einzelfall muss
das nicht so sein einzelfall muss das nicht so sein ich denke jetzt also ich gehe nicht davon
aus dass ich bedeuten mehr verdienen würde jetzt wenn ich studiert hätte oder die krasse
geilere bedingungen hätte warum geht denn dogecoin gerade so ab aber wegen dem twitter logo
waren
ich meine eigentlich ist das wie geld drucken oder die kaufen dogecoin machen dann das twitter logo
zu einem dogecoin ding und haben fettkohle damit verdient weil jetzt der kurs hoch geht also ich
fast schon wie geld drucken wenn du wenn wenn wenn die twitter gehört du hattest doch auch
mal was sat ip zeugs bei dir laufen also klassische sat ip mit receiver im keller und und
oder ne besser gesagt tuner im keller receiver dann im wohnzimmer dann sat ip dazwischen das habe ich
nicht ich benutze aktuell aber sat ip allerdings lokal auf dem auf dem gerät also ich habe ja so
eine box mit einem achtfach tuner ich habe auch wie heißt dieses ding es ist möglich dass es dieses
teil ist ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher aus dem kopf ich halte ich halte es für möglich dass es
das teil ist was ich hab
ne ne mein teil das sieht das sieht anders aus uno ich habe irgendwas mit uno irgendwas mit uno habe ich
ich glaube das teil habe ich ja so und ich benutze das halt nichts mit dem standard zeug hat meins ein
color display ich glaube nicht oder doch kann schon sein also ich benutze das teil nicht standard das
standard zeug ist aus meiner sicht nicht zu gebrauchen
das da kommst du dir vor wie mit einem fernseher 1990 das standard zeug außerdem ist die
serienaufnahme funktion schrott das einzig gute an dem ding ist dass es ein achtfach tuner hat und
linux was du drauf laufen lassen kannst der rest schockt nicht wirklich also ich würde es dafür
nicht kaufen auch die kode integration ist ein müll die standard integration ich habe jetzt die
kombination laufen ich habe
TV Headend auf der Box drauf, weil er läuft ja, also mit dem Standardbetriebssystem kannst du eh vergessen, auch mit diesem Community-Standardbetriebssystem kannst du es vergessen, man braucht Open, ich habe vergessen, wie das heißt, OpenPTV oder so, OpenATV, ja, genau, das braucht man, das ist ein halbwegs neuer Kernel und neue Tools und sowas,
da gibt es auch TV Headend, so, was ich jetzt gemacht habe auf dem Ding, ich habe TV Headend installiert und damit TV Headend die Tuner gescheit benutzen kann, weil die Tuner selbst und mit TV Headend backen rum oder funktionieren gar nicht, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ich habe SAT-IP drauflaufen, SAT-IP für die 8-fach-Tuner und TV Headend erkennt direkt die SAT-IP-Tuner,
also ist quasi so eine kleine Zwischenschicht zwischen TV Headend und den Tunern und dann habe ich auf meinem Shield-TV im Wohnzimmer, habe ich Kodi laufen mit TV Headend-Plugin, das ist für mich, für Fernsehsachen, die beste Kombination, die ich bisher hatte, du hast ein komplett offenes System, kannst machen, was du willst, kriegst die Aufnahmen auch wieder raus, falls du die mal umziehen willst, hast mehr als genug Speicher mit einer ordentlichen Festplatte drin, ich habe sogar eine SSD-Club drin, ich glaube, ich habe sogar eine SSD drin,
ja, versucht aber nicht mit dem Standardbetriebssystem oder mit diesem Community-Standard, mit dem Community-Extensions für das Standardbetriebssystem, das ist schon 2-3 Jahre her, ne, 2 Jahre her, wo wir das, haben wir uns auf dem Stream angeguckt, wo ich damit rumgebastelt habe, ich habe vergessen, wie das Ding heißt,
ich weiß jemand von euch, wie das Standardbetriebssystem heißt, was die eigentlich alle empfehlen, was ich aber total schrottig fand,
weil es ur-ur-uralte Linux-Körner drauf hatte, ja, also OpenATV ist es und dann gibt es auch aktuelles TV Headend und sowas, das ist eine gute Kombi, das ist also das einzig Gute, warum man die Kiste halt verwenden kann, ist, weil es einen 8-fach-Tuner drin hat und eine schöne Box ist mit einer internen Festplatte und einem Linux drauf, die Kombination ist gut, die Software, die da mitgeliefert wird und auch das, wie das manche Leute benutzen, finde ich komplett schrottig,
ja, aber, aber, OpenATV ist gut, nochmal die Repos gucken, ach, keine Ahnung, das kann ich aber in der Kombination empfehlen, anderweitig nicht, ey, easy, gar kein Problem, funktioniert, funktioniert, wir haben mal was ähnliches gemacht, wobei wir die Dinger nicht an hatten, wir hatten die Klamotten nicht an,
ach so, da hat die auch, die auch, der, wir,
wir haben, wir haben mal was ähnliches gemacht, allerdings war das bei uns im Büro, das war nicht im, das war nicht im Rechenzentrum, wir hatten bei uns im Büro ein paar Switche stehen, so drei, vier, drei, vier, äh, Cisco-Switche und die konnte man ja auch ordentlich hochdrehen lassen, die Lüfter von den Dingern und da haben wir auch manchmal was dahinter getrocknet, das war aber so, zur Hälfte, zur Hälfte, weil es ganz praktisch ist und zur anderen Hälfte, just for fun, so,
ist das hier Barus, oder?
War down, wieso? Archive?
Nö, geht doch alles?
Archive am Start?
Was, Wublos ist down?
Wirklich?
Warum?
Ich hab, also, ich hab, ich hab die Domain umgezogen,
ich hab die Domain umgezogen,
war outdated und hat's
ausgemacht.
Ja, wir,
dann leiten wir doch einfach,
das kann ich nachher
im DNS machen, dann leiten wir
doch einfach die normale Domain aufs
Archive um, oder?
Ist doch die, ist doch die bessere Variante, als einfach
ausschalten. Also, kann ich nebenbei
machen, ich kann meine VM mit, mit,
ähm,
ich, ich mach das, ich mach das nebenbei, Chat.
Geht, geht gleich, geht gleich wieder.
Ich laufe mich nebenbei ein
bei Cloudflare und
mach einen C-Record-Eintrag.
Äh, nicht C-Record,
C-Name-Record-Eintrag.
Nick, danke schön für den Sub.
Relax, Ponga-Subscription.
Nee, nee.
Kann man nicht so sagen.
Also, wir haben bei uns,
also, früher
hier beim alten Arbeitgeber
hatten wir zwei Studierte, die haben
es im Support versauert.
Kann man nicht sagen,
dass es sich da
für die groß gelohnt hätte.
Ha, das haben sie bestimmt
mitgekriegt.
So, ich mach das mal kurz schnell hier.
Namecheap?
Login?
Okay, ich mach das.
Ich mach das doch nicht?
Ich hätte eigentlich gedacht,
ich war hier schon eingeloggt.
Doch, Namecheap, bin ich doch.
Geht doch.
Keine Ahnung, was das wieder für Schmerzen hat.
Verification Code.
Oh, shit, Mann.
Ich mach's. Okay, Leute, ich mach das nach dem Stream.
Verification Code.
Nee, ich hatte es ja vergessen.
Ja, es ist ja nicht
verkehrt. Ich denke mal,
so ein bisschen theoretischer Hintergrund
bringt schon was.
Also, ich hatte nach der Ausbildung beim
Provider 33.500,
das weiß ich noch.
Was war das denn, was du vor einigen
Jahren auf dem Server mit der TV-Karte
hattest und was nutzt du da drauf?
Du meinst das alte, die alte
Kiste, du meinst dieses, dieses Ding?
Du meinst das
mit der TV, wo ich die USB-TV-Karte
dran hatte? Das war so ein Teil
hier. Mit...
Mit, äh, hier.
Das war ja quasi so eine externe,
eine externe Festplatte mit
Microcontroller.
Da hab ich das offizielle
Betriebssystem, glaub ich, von denen drauf gehabt.
Nee, das stimmt nicht. Da haben wir Arch Linux
drauf gemacht. Lull.
Wir haben Arch Linux
drauf gemacht. Das weiß ich noch.
Wir haben nämlich Arch Linux drauf gemacht, weil
die...
Passwort... Nein, ich hab mein Passwort nicht vergessen.
Wir haben Arch Linux drauf gemacht,
weil der Kern,
der Kernel, zu alt
war von
dem mitgelieferten OS
und deswegen haben wir Arch Linux
drauf gemacht und einen eigenen
Kernel kompiliert.
Das weiß ich noch.
Und dann, dann lief das
halbwegs.
Ich mach das jetzt, ich mach das übrigens
jetzt doch nebenbei, Leute, mit der
mit der Domain. Ich muss mich
jetzt Nummer zwei faktormäßig anmelden
auf der anderen Seite. Das ist grad wieder richtig
zu, zu
secure alles.
Highly secure.
Da können wir nämlich, da können wir nämlich die Domain
jetzt gleich fixen. Machen wir jetzt.
Submit.
So.
Also.
Was, was braucht man denn, dass das funktioniert?
Hier. Archive.woblos
geht. Woblos.tv
geht nicht.
Also brauche ich ein CNAME
für Woblos.tv.
Ich mach das mal schnell.
Manage DNS.
So. Normales
CNAME.
CNAME?
Archive.woblos.tv
So. Jetzt schauen wir mal, ob's
funktioniert. Bin ich mal gespannt.
Die
Namensauflösung dürfte ein bisschen dauern.
Aber demnächst
sollte das wieder funktionieren.
Sollte gleich, sollte gleich wieder
tun. Schauen wir gleich mal.
Können wir mal in der
Viertelstunde, Viertelstunde gucken.
Wie's dann, wie's dann aussieht.
Hast du HD Plus?
Ne, hab ich nicht.
Hab ich auch nicht eingesehen
mir das zu kaufen. Ganz ehrlich.
Das ist der einzige Vorteil der
öffentlich-rechtlichen Sender,
dass es HD quasi
umsonst gibt
dazu. Ich mein, die kriegen auch genug Geld.
Irgendwie. Wie viel hatten die letztes Jahr?
77 Milliarden oder sowas.
Heftig, was da, was da für Geld
verblasen wird.
Welches Tool hattest du zum Verschlüsseln
der Festplatte genommen? Veracrypt, korrekt.
Also unter Windows, wohlgemerkt.
Unter Linux natürlich nicht.
Wobei du, wobei du unter Linux
mittlerweile
Veracrypt-Volumes out of the box
mounten kannst.
Falls du mal Rescue,
Rescue-Disk dran musst.
Meine Eltern wollen einfach nur problemlos aufnehmen
und viel speichern, normal TV schon. Geht das damit?
Das ist schon
die Kombination, die ich hab. Ein bisschen was
für technikversierte Leute. Sollte mal
irgendwas nicht funktionieren,
was sehr selten vorkommt, aber
durchaus
schon mal sein kann.
Also einmal im Jahr oder so, oder
vielleicht, ja, so einmal im Jahr
ist mal irgendwas und die Kiste muss vielleicht mal
neu gestartet werden.
Könnte schwierig werden, je nachdem wie gut du die
eingerichtet hast, ob da deine Eltern mit klarkommen
oder nicht. Bei mir ist es einfach, ich starte
die Kiste neu, logge mich per SSH
ein, starte mein,
mein, ja, mein
Skript quasi
und dann geht wieder alles.
Das schaltet die mitgelieferte
Oberfläche aus, schaltet
SAT-IP ein, TV
Headend ein und fertig.
Serious Max, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das geht,
weil
ist das ein Zertifikat, was nur für Archive
ausgestellt ist?
Dann geht das ja nicht.
Wupp, es ist nicht Wupp, es ist Wupp, Lortz.
Ne, geht immer noch nicht.
Ich glaub, das ist jetzt einfach mal ein
DNS-Cache, der rumspackt.
Gucken wir mal. Gucken wir mal in der
VM, was passiert.
Ich hab mehr YouTube-Tabs offen
als du. Ja, ich hab
viele Tabs offen. Ich mein, irgendwo muss ich ja mit
meinem 460 GB RAM hin.
Diesen Satz verstehe ich nicht.
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Bei was?
Was muss man dafür installieren?
Bind?
Nicht wirklich.
Oder?
Moin, Chainlore.
Auch mal wieder am Start.
Bind? Aber
Bind ist doch...
Ich will doch kein Bind installieren.
Was ist denn das hier schon wieder für ein Kack, man?
Der erste Tag war ganz okay.
Was? Drill. Drill hab ich
noch nie verwendet.
Ne, gibt's ja auch nicht.
Wir können auch Pac-Man
SQ?
Ist es? Ne.
Oder nur
Q?
Pac-Man Minus F?
Was ist Epic 4?
IRC Development?
Monk IS? Alter, was?
Aber Bind
Tools gibt's doch gar nicht.
Gibt keine Bind
Tools. Es gibt nur
Bind.
Ja, installier mal halt Bind.
Ich mein, ich muss ja nicht starten.
Dick. Wobblords.
Wobblords.TV
Es ist aber nicht richtig,
dass da ein A-Record
zurückkommt.
Da sollte eigentlich
ein C-Name kommen.
Wollen wir schon mal hier gucken?
Achso, das geht ja gegen meinen Cache.
Du hast recht. Warum steht denn da jemand?
Ah ja, das ist richtig so.
Jaja, das ist gut so.
Ja, wahrscheinlich. Ne, mein Router hat wahrscheinlich
gecached. Ja, das ist richtig so.
Das sieht okay aus.
C-Name auf dem Router.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich es anders machen soll.
Weil
das Zertifikat ist, glaub ich, nur für Archiv.
Sollte jetzt funktionieren.
Ich mein, mehr als kaputt gehen kann es nicht.
Hattest du nicht in deiner 3, 4, 5
Moment, das war ne 2 HE-Kiste.
Ne, 4 HE-Kiste
war das, glaub ich.
Ne 4 HE-Kiste.
3 oder 4, ich weiß es gar nicht.
Ich glaub ne 4 HE-Kiste. 3 ist so untypisch.
Einfach die IP als A-Record.
Ja, das bringt dir aber nichts, wenn das Zertifikat nur fürs Archiv ausgestellt ist.
Ist das ein Wildcard-Zertifikat?
Ansonsten
bringt das nichts, wenn ich die IP eintrage.
Ach, das ist ein Wildcard-Zertifikat.
Dann ist easy.
Dann kann ich auch
die IP nehmen.
Sag doch gleich, dass es ein Wildcard-Zertifikat ist.
Löschen.
Add.
Dann ist es ja easy. Wusste ich nicht, dass es ein Wildcard-Zertifikat ist.
So.
Jetzt.
Gucken wir mal.
IP League. OMG, Alter.
IP League.
Jetzt dauert es noch ein bisschen, bis er es gecheckt hat.
Gnome? Ich weiß nicht, wie du auf Gnome kommst.
Also ja, ich hatte ne 4 HE-Kiste.
Da war ne TV-Karte.
Da war so ne
Win-Dings-Tuner
Win-Win-Tune, wie auch immer.
Karte, Dual-Tuner-Karte
drin. Ja, doch.
Hatte ich, ja.
Die Kiste habe ich auch noch.
Aber die habe ich nicht mehr im Einsatz, weil die einfach nur
oversized as fuck war
und vor allem
unsinnig Strom gefressen hat.
Und mittlerweile eigentlich auch schon veraltet ist.
Habe gerade ein
Arch-Jungs mit einem Gnome-Desktop installiert.
Normalerweise hat man doch beim Einloggen
die Möglichkeit, den Display-Server auszuwählen.
Wayland vs. X-Rock.
Die Option gibt es bei mir nicht.
Weiß ich nicht, was man da für Packages
unter Arch installieren muss.
Oder ob es da irgendwelche Meta-Packages
für gibt.
Weil ich kann Wayland in der
VM nicht gescheit benutzen. Deswegen
ist es X
und bleibt wahrscheinlich
auch X.
Der lokale Cache ist noch drin.
Das bringt nichts. Ich müsste es auf meinem
Router löschen.
Natel ist Schweizerdeutsch für Handy.
Natel? Ja, also
ich habe immer noch ein iPhone.
Ich habe aktuell ein iPhone 14.
Ich habe mir sogar letztens ein iPad Pro
gekauft. Richtig unsinnige
Geldverschwendung. Aber hat was.
Richtig, das ist zwar ein bisschen schwerer,
aber größer und nices Display
und so. Also,
ja, was das angeht.
Ich habe jetzt zwei Handys.
Ich habe vom neuen Arbeitgeber jetzt auch
eins. Ein iPhone
12, glaube ich, ist das.
Und ich habe mein iPhone 14.
Ich habe aber auch Android-Geräte hier.
Ich bin der Meinung, es macht überhaupt keinen Sinn,
sich darüber zu streiten, ob jetzt
Android besser ist oder
iOS oder
Android oder Apple oder was auch immer.
Also erstens
soll jeder benutzen, was ihm am besten liegt.
Und zweitens haben alle beide Systeme
wahrscheinlich sogar
hätte, wahrscheinlich hätte sogar Windows-System
seine Vorteile.
Windows, Windows Mobile.
Wie hieß das Ding? Seine Vorteile
gehabt. Wobei, das war schon echt schrottig.
Windows Phone, genau.
Aber
es haben beide Systeme Vorteile.
Nämlich, zum Beispiel, dass
alles, was um Automatisierung geht
und der Android einfach um
Längen besser
ist, als was du
jemals wahrscheinlich mit
iOS machen kannst.
Das liegt aber auch ein bisschen so an der Philosophie
dahinter.
Apple
mag halt manche Sachen
nicht. Und wenn Apple Sachen nicht mag,
dann kannst du in der Regel davon ausgehen, dass sie auch nicht gehen.
Und der Android
mögen manche Sachen standardmäßig nicht gehen,
aber du kannst es meistens trotzdem irgendwie machen.
Also was du zum Beispiel bei
Android Easy machen kannst, ist
ein Background-Job
einrichten, der alle
15 Sekunden
irgendeinen Server queriert oder so.
Kannst du mit Tasker machen,
kannst du mit irgendeinem Shell-Skript machen,
wenn du da eine Umgebung hast, das geht.
Unter Android funktioniert
unter iOS funktioniert das nicht gescheit.
Weil
die Sachen werden nach spätestens,
wenn du irgendeine Schleife startest, beispielsweise
in Workflows oder so, dann
wird das nach glaube ich spätestens
10 Sekunden beendet.
Hast du ein Custom-ROM auf dein Android-Handy,
ich habe kein Android-Handy, ich habe Android-Tablets
und die haben Custom-ROMs.
Ich habe zwei
Fire HD 10
hängen als
hier an der Wand als Dashboard für
meine Heimautomatisierung
und die anderen Sachen habe ich alle nicht mehr
in Verwendung. Auf meinem Shield-Tablet
habe ich irgendein Lineage
OS, aber das
benutze ich gar nicht mehr, das Shield-Tablet.
Und ansonsten, ich habe eigentlich nur die zwei
Fire HD 10s
im Einsatz mit
Android, die geflasht sind.
Den Rest benutze ich nicht mehr.
Also die Hardware, die ich bekommen habe auf der Arbeit,
ist wirklich nice. Das ist, ich glaube, irgendein
i7-Notebook mit 32G RAM.
Was? CalyxOS?
Das kenne ich nicht.
Auch irgendein Android...
Ja, ist es, ist ein Android.
Device Support?
Ja, nur Pixels.
Ja, da habe ich nichts von.
Hast du freie OS-Auswahl?
Ne.
Habe ich nicht.
Zumindest habe ich noch nicht genervt
deswegen. Aktuell haben sie mir ein Windows-Notebook
ohne irgendwelche Tools hingeknallt.
Aber hey,
ich werde schon mal gucken, wie man das
auf die Reihe kriegt und im Zweifelsfall
auch nerven.
Was ist eigentlich nur der Nachteil von einem Wildcard-Zertifikat?
Der einzige
Nachteil, der mir da jetzt
so spontan ein... Okay, zwei Nachteile.
Zwei Nachteile fallen mir spontan
ein. Der erste
ist allerdings nicht so wild.
Du kannst es halt nicht wirklich gut kontrollieren,
welches Zertifikat für was verwendet wird,
weil du eins für alles verwendest.
Und wenn du verschiedene Subdomains
hast, wo verschiedene Leute für zuständig sind
oder verschiedene Teams für zuständig sind,
ja, ist das vielleicht eher wünschenswert,
dass das nicht selbst ausgestellt wird.
Aber das viel entscheidendere ist,
dass du
mit Wildcard-Zertifikaten
schneller, wenn du nicht aufpasst,
in Let's Encrypt-Limits
läufst, als mit einzelnen Zertifikaten.
Weil du kannst so ein Wildcard-Zertifikat
glaube ich nur fünfmal
oder siebenmal, ich glaube fünfmal, oder?
Nur fünfmal
alle
14 Tage
ich weiß die Limits aus dem Kopf
nicht, renewen.
Das ist nicht schlimm normalerweise,
weil die laufen drei Monate.
Aber wenn du Sachen testest,
dann
willst du das vielleicht auch mal öfters machen
und nicht jedes Mal auf Staging umschalten.
Also mit Wildcard-Zertifikaten
läufst du viel schneller in
Let's Encrypt-Limits
als mit einzelnen Zertifikaten.
Es gibt aber einen Trick,
wenn man in
Let's Encrypt-Limits gelaufen ist,
einfach noch eine zweite
Domain mit anfordern.
In dem Request.
Weil Let's Encrypt limitiert
die Request und nicht
die einzelnen Domains.
Also wenn du ein Zertifikat anforderst
für
kekel.lull.de
und du
forderst gleichzeitig
kekel.kekw.lull.de
dann ist es ein neuer Request.
Das geht, ja.
Dementsprechend kannst du auch
Wildcard-Zertifikate und
Subdomain-Zertifikate
zusammen anfordern und sowas.
Und dann kann man die Limit ein bisschen austricksen.
Das funktioniert.
Also was verpasst? Nö.
Wir machen heute auch nichts großartiges.
Kann man ein
Wildcard-Zertifikat
automatisch beantragen?
Ja, das ist ja der Sinn von Let's Encrypt.
Dass das so weit wie möglich automatisch funktioniert.
Hyper-V habe ich noch nie verwendet.
Welche Tastatur benutzt du?
Beziehungsweise welche kannst du empfehlen?
Also ich habe auf der Arbeit
habe ich eine Ducky One Skyline.
Die liegt da jetzt im Schrank.
Die habe ich heute mit hingenommen.
Und eine Logitech G502.
Und hier daheim habe ich eine Logitech-Tastatur.
Da weiß ich aus dem Kopf auch gerade gar nicht, welche das ist.
Die würde ich jetzt nicht so unbedingt empfehlen.
Die ist aber, die ist okay.
Ja, das ist in Ordnung.
Das ist jetzt keine Tastatur, mit der mich voll in Verzückung
versetzt, aber die ist in Ordnung.
Was habe ich denn für eine Tastatur?
G500, lass mal kurz gucken.
G512.
So eine Handball-Auflage.
Kann man eigentlich sein Apple-iPhone auf Viren
überprüfen?
Ich gehe davon aus, dass es irgendwelche
Viren, Anti-Viren-Software
für iPhones gibt. Wie groß die ist,
allein schon, weil sich das
sich wahrscheinlich gut verkaufen lässt
bei manchen Leuten.
Ob die sinnvoll funktionieren und ob die
gut was erkennen und so.
Keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht.
Da habe ich mich nicht bisher mit beschäftigt.
Ja, ich glaube, so einfach ist das bei mir nicht.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Ich glaube, du kriegst
dann ein Zertifikat mit zwei
Namen drinne.
Keine Ducky für zu Hause. Ne, ich will die auch daheim
nicht verwenden.
Ducky One Skyline fehlt ist, dass
du eine gescheite
Software hast, was unter Windows
sehr praktisch ist. Gerade wenn man für Games
was ummappen will oder
kleine Makros braucht, die halt auch so aussehen
als kommen sie wirklich aus der Tastatur
und nicht als kommen sie aus
irgendeinem
Autohotkey oder so.
Ja, das geht mit der Ducky
nur sehr beschränkt, was Makros angeht.
Für daheim ist die nix.
Und ich glaube, fürs Gaming
wird die mir auch nicht gut gefallen.
Ja, die klicken ziemlich.
Die klicken ziemlich, die Tastatur.
Fehlt dir da nicht der NumBlock?
Ich hab nen NumBlock.
Alle meine Tastaturen haben einen
NumBlock.
Ich finde nicht sinnvoll, auf
einen NumBlock zu verzichten.
Wie ist das bei euch, Leute?
Habt ihr noch nen NumBlock?
Ich hab einige Kollegen, von denen weiß ich,
dass die
mögen gerne so Mini-Tastaturen.
Die haben dann, da gibt's, da gibt's
teilweise auch Tastaturen,
die haben gar keine
so
die haben doch nicht mal diesen Block mit den
Pfeiltasten und sowas.
Die haben quasi nur dieses normale
Keyboard-Feld und sonst
nichts. Das ist halt ein Drittel kleiner,
die Tastatur.
60% Höhe.
Ja, okay. Ich mag das
nicht. Ich hab
so ne richtig fette Tastatur.
P-Pro-Fett.
Oh ne, wir gucken uns heute keine Sachen
mehr an. Ich hab gesagt, wir gucken uns auch kurz 1-2 Videos an,
bevor wir dann pennen gehen, aber
ne.
Ich guck mir jetzt
gleich noch, ich guck mir jetzt gleich
noch irgendwie
irgendwie ne Folge von
irgendeiner Serie an oder so oder
oder guck irgendwas kleines auf YouTube
irgendwas.
Gut, dann geh ich pennen morgen.
Homeoffice, dann bin ich wieder ein bisschen fitter.
Muss sagen, das schlaucht schon
ganz schön, ja. Du hast
am ersten Arbeitstag total viel neues Zeug.
Nur neue Leute.
Ihr wisst ja, wie ich so mit
zwischenmenschlichen sozialen Sachen so hab, ja.
Nur
neue Leute und auch nur
neue Sachen, neue Abkürzungen, neue Dinger
und verstehst eigentlich noch gar
nix, ja. Schon 2
Dailies gehabt aber heute. Also
wenn schon eins, dann Dailies.
Habt ihr noch einen NumBlock? 57%
sagen ja. Interessant.
Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich den Anteil der Leute, die so
auf so Mini-Tastaturen schwören,
höher eingeschätzt. Aber die meisten
sind anscheinend noch normal und mögen
auch NumBlocks.
Sogar im Discord schreibt jemand, ich hab
zu viele Tabs offen.
Ja.
Okay. Hast du dir
schon mal Linux wollten?
Also mir sagt der Name
was. Ich bin mir jetzt nicht ganz
sicher, ob wir das schon mal aussuchen.
Ob wir das schon ausprobiert haben.
Wenn, dann hat's mich nicht überzeugt.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob wir das schon ausprobiert
haben oder nicht. Ne, haben wir
nicht. Ich glaub auch nicht, dass
es kann sein,
dass ich mir mal angeguckt hab die Webseite
und dann zum Schluss gekommen bin, das will
ich erst gar nicht ausprobieren. Es kann sein,
dass es das gewesen ist.
Und unschlüssig. Ich weiß nicht
mehr genau. Achso, das
sollte ich mir ja angucken. Hat jemand
gepostet.
Können wir uns das noch geben?
19 Minuten. Also das heißt
jetzt nur mal so, das ist das volle
Reaction Game.
Ich reacte jetzt auf ein Video,
wo einer auf ein Blogpost
in einer Reaction
reactet.
Okay, dann reacten wir auch mal.
Meta Reaction.
So, jetzt muss ich erst mal
den Tab
finden, wo ich die Musik laufen hab.
Okay, also, auf geht's.
Ready? What? Oh, das ist der Hyper
aktive Wim User, gell?
Oder? Ja, glaub schon.
Why our work culture sucks.
Okay.
Und warum suckt die work culture?
Was ist das überhaupt für ein Blog, was er sich da anguckt?
Bestimmt Medium
oder sowas.
Why our work culture sucks.
Okay, last year after finding myself
between two jobs, I interviewed
with a bunch of startups.
Dazu kann ich nur sagen.
I stream on Windows!
Alter!
Okay, das ist der Hyper
aktive Wim Benutzer.
Shut up! Okay?
I can't help it, that I stream
on Windows. Okay?
It's just so much
better for video than Linux, okay?
I still can't get my video and audio to even
work rarely, okay? So shut up!
Ist überhaupt kein Problem, ich stream auch unter Windows.
Shut up!
Der ist ja gut, Alter.
Last year after finding myself
between two jobs, I interviewed with a bunch of startups
in Paris. All successful
businesses. That's
good. You know, I'm not gonna lie to you, if you were
interviewing with unsuccessful
businesses, I would change my strategy.
Hat er nicht ohne Recht.
Auf der anderen Seite.
Wie successful
die so unterm Strich sind, weiß man ja
bei vielen am Anfang gar nicht, wenn man sich
tabutiert.
Don von Bronn
schreibt, heute Zusage
für neue Stelle bekommen. Nice.
Gratz.
A very French thing to say.
De la creme, de la creme.
Looking for experienced developers to
consolidate their tech teams. Alright.
I discuss with CEOs and CTOs.
Hahaha.
Okay, der Blogschreiber
findet sich aber auch schon furchtbar
geil, oder?
It's about their visions
for business, project management
and company culture. Also seriously,
wenn ich
mich bewerben würde irgendwo als
Techniker, das letzte
auf, das letzte
worauf ich Bock hätte, ist mit dem
CEO seine
Vision für Business und
Projektmanagement zu diskutieren.
What?
Sind die komplett
lost alle, oder wie?
Das interessiert mich auch überhaupt nicht.
Die Hauptsache, die haben gute
Arbeitsbedingungen, bezahlen viel.
Ich mag die Kollegen, ich mag die Arbeit,
ich mag die Technik. Was der Typ
für eine Business Vision hat, ist
mir erstmal wurscht,
ja. Wenn das natürlich
zusammenpasst, alles ist noch besser, aber
nix, was ich bei einer Bewerbung fragen würde,
wie ist denn, wie ist denn, hey, hallo
CEO, kann ich mal kurz mit dir
reden, wie ist denn deine Business Vision?
Appreciate that.
Let's see, okay. I would often quote
the famous Basecamp books.
So I don't know the Basecamp... Was?
Ich hab auch keine Ahnung, was das ist.
I don't know what they're famous for, I just, I've never seen them.
Basecamp is a famous project management
startup. They wrote a series of equally
famous entrepreneurship books
advocating for a shift... Sind die
die sind so famous, dass ich noch nie
was davon gehört hab.
... towards a culture closer to their own.
Hä? Okay, so am I
the stupid one or is it not that famous?
Which one? I also don't...
Ich denk mir auch, so famous kann's ja nicht sein, oder?
... books and I only shoot
shotguns and drink beer. Is that a problem?
I also write ATVs or
Segways while shooting shotguns and drinking beer.
Is this problematic?
Was will er von uns? The Ruby
guy, okay, okay,
okay, maybe both,
okay, could be both. Shape up,
remote work, rework. It doesn't
have to be crazy at work, getting
real. Moment, seh ich das
richtig?
Die Bücher heißen so,
oder was? Shape up,
remote, rework?
It doesn't have to be crazy at
work, getting real?
All great book...
What? Okay,
wir schauen jetzt mal, wie famous
diese Books sind.
It doesn't, doesn't have
to be crazy at work.
Okay, okay, die sind wohl wirklich
relativ famous.
Da muss man tatsächlich sagen,
anscheinend
sind die Bücher doch recht bekannt.
Ratings und auch ganz gut.
Ich kenn sie nicht.
Ey, das ist der,
das ist der Ruby on Rails Erfinder.
Ach, das meint er eben mit dem
Ruby Guy, oder was?
Ach, ja, weil das ist, das ist der Ruby on Rails Erfinder.
All the great books
filled with great advice. Getting
real.
Nothing
like software engineers.
Aber,
aber, warum redet er denn bitteschön
mit dem CEO, woran er sich als Programmierer
beworben hat, über so ein Shit?
Hitting the streets and, you know,
getting real. Hey,
hey man, you know what?
Last week... Okay, da ist auch
ein Geister im Sidetracked werden.
Jetzt mal eine Frage, wenn ich das gucke, bin ich um
23 Uhr nicht fertig. Wo geht
es denn los? Wo kommt denn das
Interessante jetzt?
Okay, no one is actually doing it.
What book? Oh, of course,
shape up remote. Yo, I'm prison
mother. No, we don't do that here.
Leute, ich kann mir das nicht angucken.
Der ist mir zu hyperaktiv.
Das ist ein guter,
ein guter Wimlets Player.
Aber was will uns,
was will uns der Blog-Artikel-Schreiber
dann überhaupt sagen?
Der will uns sagen, dass es,
dass es nice ist,
nicht, oh,
was geht da im Chat ab, man?
Der hat ganz, der hat ganz viele
der macht teilweise wirklich ganz unterhaltsame
Videos, aber das meiste ist mir zu anstrengend.
Das kann ich mir nicht geben. Wir lesen
den einfach selber, okay, weil ihr seid...
Why our work culture
suck.
Oh, meine Augen.
Ich kann den jetzt nicht mehr lesen.
Viel zu hell.
Was, was, was will, was will der Dude uns
mit dem Artikel eigentlich sagen?
Ne, Neowim haben wir noch gar nicht gemacht.
Remote work, that's
amazing and great and future. No.
No?
Warum nicht?
How many companies were forced into remote work?
Naja, ähm,
richtig,
ja, da gibt es sicherlich einige
davon, die sich
während der Corona-Zeit gezwungen sahen
Homeoffice anzubieten oder
nicht mehr zu existieren.
Ja, das gab es einige.
Das, das, das stimmt, ja.
Ja, da, ja,
das gibt's auch, dass die festge...
Mein alter Arbeitgeber war so einer,
hey, es funktioniert wunderbar während
Corona remote arbeiten, aber jetzt kommt man wieder
alle ins Büro.
Äh, das lese ich mir jetzt nicht durch, das ist mir viel zu lang.
Klar, da habe ich heute, da habe ich heute nicht
genug Aufmerksamkeitsspanne für, um mir das anzugucken.
Aber
das gab's zuhauf,
ja. Also ich,
wie gesagt, ich hab das, ich hab das bei meinem alten
Arbeitgeber gesehen, die haben auch immer
gesagt, wenn du sie darauf angesprochen hast,
boah, das funktioniert ja alles ganz toll.
Und wenn du dann gesagt hast, ja,
warum sollen die Leute jetzt 50% wieder
in die Firma kommen? Ja, weil
wir von Menschen für Menschen
da sein sollen und bla,
bla, bla. Da wurde sich ein Shit
aus den Fingern gesaugt, Leute, ich sag's
euch, das ist echt nicht normal gewesen.
Ja, wisst ihr, ich arbeite
auch in der IT, weil ich so Bock hab auf
von Menschen für Menschen, ja.
Das ist der Grund, das ist der Grund, warum ich hauptsächlich
äh, Computerzeug mache, weil
ich so oft von Menschen für Menschen stehe.
Ja, und das haben die auch erzählt,
Sarix hat sich das gemerkt, ja, auf meiner alten
Arbeit haben die wirklich erzählt,
äh, wir
können nicht hauptsächlich
Homeoffice machen, weil wir haben als Arbeitgeber
ja auch eine Fürsorgepflicht
und eine unserer Pflichten ist,
dass die Arbeitnehmer nicht vereinsamen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es denen schon mal in den
Sinn gekommen ist, aber man kann auch
mit anderen Leuten interagieren,
ohne dass das auf der Arbeit
stattfindet.
Also es gibt ja durchaus Leute,
die arbeiten im Homeoffice,
und gehen danach
raus, ein bisschen rumlaufen mit ein paar
anderen Leuten, spazieren oder treffen sich
mit anderen Leuten oder labern
im Discord mit anderen Leuten, telefonieren
mit anderen Leuten, besaufen
sich mit anderen Leuten, gehen Gassi
mit anderen Hundebesitzern, was auch immer.
Da gibt's mehr als genug.
Meinst du, das macht einen Unterschied?
Man kann sogar
im Twitch-Chat mit anderen Leuten reden.
Ja, das stimmt schon.
Ist auf jeden Fall was dran.
Wisst ihr, eine Sache fand ich
während Corona auch sehr nice,
und zwar, dass die Leute voneinander
Abstand gehalten haben.
So dieses
auf die Pelle rücken,
das ist in der Zeit
weniger gewesen. Ich glaube, dass
das bisschen hängen geblieben ist,
dass es insgesamt weniger ist, aber
ja,
es gibt halt auch Leute, die machen das gerne.
Ja, ne?
Das hört sich fast so an.
Aber das waren ja alles nur Ausreden.
Da waren einfach so viele
Humorchefs am Start, die gedacht
haben, wenn sie nicht durch die Büros laufen
und die Leute vorm Rechner sitzen sehen,
dann machen die alle nix. Wobei sie
halt in Wirklichkeit,
wenn er dann durchgelaufen ist,
und wirklich nix zu tun hatten,
halt gefaked haben, dass sie was tun.
Ob das so viel sinnvoller ist, sei mal
bezweifelt, ja.
Und dass sie anderweitig aber
viel mehr machen,
dadurch, dass sie vielleicht ausgeschlafener
sind, fitter sind, leistungsfähiger
sind, motivierter sind,
ja. Nicht mal sinnlos hin und her pendeln,
müssen Zeit verlieren, auch was von ihrem Leben
haben, also quasi bessere Arbeit abliefern
und mehr von ihrem Leben drumherum
haben. Das sind halt so Sachen,
die kommen denen dann irgendwie nicht in die,
nicht in den Kopf, ja.
Ja, da hast du Glück gehabt, da hast du Glück gehabt.
Homeoffice-Vertrag, Poggers.
Also ich bin wirklich froh, dass
ich den Arbeitgeber
jetzt gewechselt hab.
Das erste, was ich heute gehört hab, ist,
dass die alle
einmal alle 14 Tage anrücken,
und
ich werde das jetzt erstmal so machen,
dass ich jeden Dienstag, jeden Dienstag komme,
also zumindest
nächste Woche nochmal auch Dienstag,
obwohl ich diese Woche da gewesen bin,
montags schon,
und dann mal gucken.
Also ich werde das, denke ich, auch perspektivisch
alle 14 Tage machen.
Aber das ist doch schon mal was,
wenn die das von sich aus alle sagen,
ja, dass das so ist. Und nicht,
wir sind von Menschen für Menschen da,
deswegen müsst ihr anrücken.
Es ist keine, das ist kein Argument,
was mich jetzt bei irgendeinem
IT-Keller-Hock
und im Bildschirm-Hook-Job
überzeugt als Argument für,
das muss ich nur unbedingt vor Ort machen,
und es geht nirgendswo anders.
Ich weiß nicht,
keine Ahnung. Alle 14 Tage
finde ich sehr nice, sehr, sehr
nice, ja.
Wisst ihr, was ich jetzt mach?
Ja, noch nicht
ganz, aber, aber
fast, fast
Bad-Git-Time.
Ich bin auch echt müde heute.
Ich glaube, so müde war ich schon eine Weile.
Ich bin vereinsamt. Ja, ist das eh.
Homeoffice ist das Beste,
da hast du recht.
Alles klar,
wir sehen uns. Bis denn.
See you.